quand on voit la situation
internationale est ce qu'on dit mais
finalement il a eu raison de ne pas se
déclarer sitôt est-ce que là il aurait
mis un drain président en campagne vu la
situation écouter la les institutions
font que nous avons aujourd'hui un
président de la république quitte en
fonction jusqu'à la dernière minute mais
qui est face à une campagne électorale
potentiel il a décalé continue à décaler
j'espère qu'il sera quand même qui
n'oubliera pas que le 4 mars et la fin
quoi et que finalement il ya une
élection présidentielle parce qu'on peut
aussi en jambes et l'élection
présidentielle
bien sûr toute la stratégie de chez
makro on sait qu'ils ne puissent avec un
temps très court ne pas avoir à rendre
des comptes et bien moi je dis à votre
micro que le président doit rendre des
comptes y compris sur sa politique et
internationale et être des candidats un
mois avant l'élection présidentielle
dont il a choisi la date je vous le
rappelle dire on aurait pu imaginer
parce qu'on dira oui lui mais ça marche
pas j'ai déjà eu des élections pendant
des jours fériés donc en fait on nous
avons à peine un mois de campagne réel
au moment de la déclaration du président
de la république quand il le décidera et
ça c'est une atteinte au bon
fonctionnement de nos institutions c'est
une guerre éclate et selon vous trahir
le message démocratique en tout cas
peut-être qu'on est en train de nous
voler l'élection présidentielle le
président qui veulent la campagne
française l'élection présidentielle
française s'il n'est pas candidat et
s'il ne présente pas son bilan et s'ils
continuent à utiliser les moyens de
l'état il ya quelque chose qui ne colle
pas mais comme je le dis souvent
métaphore cinématographique la reine ça
ose tout la mode la marque ronis aux
secousses à ça qu'on les reconnaît
[Musique]